has taken or is considering in each of
the relevant policy areas
inflation is a major concern for all of
us as Russia's war of aggression
exacerbated the rise in the price of
energy food and commodities
this has a direct impact on our citizens
and on our businesses it has become
clearer than ever that the Union's
energy security is indispensable for a
successful sustainable and inclusive
recovery from the crisis
it is a fact that high energy prices May
particularly heavily on the most
vulnerable parts of our populations
therefore alleviating energy poverty and
addressing the social consequences of
the rise in Energy prices is one of the
main priorities of the presidency
last month the council agreed its
negotiating position on the revision of
the Energy Efficiency directive which
would oblige member states to take
measures to implement Energy Efficiency
improvements for people affected by or
in risk of energy poverty
in addition the ongoing revision of the
energy performance of buildings through
directive will facilitate more targeted
financing to investments in the building
sector thus supporting vulnerable
consumers and fighting energy poverty
let me recall on 29th of June the
council also agreed its negotiating
position on the social climate fund
regulation under the fit 455 package
the new fund should help tackle energy
poverty by supporting vulnerable
households micro Enterprises and
transport users particularly affected by
the impact of the new emissions trading
system for buildings and Road Transport
the council remains ready to engage in
negotiations with the European
Parliament for a fast adoption of this
important file so the support can reach
the most vulnerable as soon as possible
what is more the council recently also
adopted a recommendation on a fair
transition to climate neutrality
this recommendation encourages member
states to put in place measures to
support those most affected by the green
transition in particular those in
vulnerable situations and to accompany
them towards economic activities that
contribute to climate and environmental
objectives
in October we will hold a conference on
tackling energy poverty focusing on the
EU approach and sharing the best
practices
the frame in the framework of the
European semester the council will adopt
on 12th of July country specific
recommendations for all the member
states
the recommendations from the commission
for
2023 take into account the Versant
economic Outlook and the higher
inflation compared to the commission's
2022 Winter forecast
as a result for 22 and 23rd it is
recommended that National fiscal and
social policies take into account
continued temporary and targeted support
to households and firms most vulnerable
to energy price hikes
the National Recovery and resilient
plans cover a broad range of reforms and
Investments that strengthen member State
social Protection Systems
these measures focus on the
effectiveness quality and resilience of
social Protection Systems and include
also specific measures addressing for
instance the inclusion of people with
disabilities increasing the adequacy and
sustainability of social benefits and
improving the living conditions of
elderly people in need of care
the European pillar of social rights
supports and guide our work in the
social policy areas the commitment of
the council and its member states to the
portal declaration and to achieving the
headline targets by 2030 was reinforced
by setting National Targets on
employment skills and a fight against
poverty
Beyond setting National targets let me
stress that important concrete
achievements have been made since the
port of summit
last month the co-legislators reached an
historic agreement on the directive on
adequate minimum wages in the EU this
should significantly contribute to
reducing invert poverty and to improving
upward social convergence
the council has also approved in June
2021 the European child guarantee to
address the problem of children at the
risk of poverty the implementation of
this recommendation is one of our
priority areas
we believe that strong political
commitment ambitious national action
plans and strong governance at National
level is crucial to ensure an effect
efficient implementation
in line with this commitment we will
organize a high-level presidency
conference entitled child support in the
context of the child guarantee later
this week on the 7th and 8th of July
Rising inflation and the impact of the
war waged by Russia in Ukraine create
real risks also for youth employment
in the framework of the implementation
of the reinforced youth guarantee the
member states can better design and put
in place policies for youth let me
recall that Council recommendation on
the reinforced youth guarantee
recognizes the Partnerships between
youth guarantee providers and other
social services including including
social housing and accessibility
Services as cross-cutting enablers for
its implementation president honorable
members I thank you for the attention
actually
thank you very much now is my pleasure
also to welcome commissioner Nicholas
Schmidt you've got a flower
dear president honorable member site
also want to thank the European
Parliament for organizing this very
important debate on the topic that
preoccupies European citizens all over
Europe
indeed Europe is at a key social
economic and political juncture we were
on a recovery path but are now facing an
unprecedented situation largely due to
Russia's war of aggression in Ukraine
this war has not only caused destruction
and the humanitarian crisis but it is
also an attack on our societies and
values in Europe
this has also generated unprecedented
challenges in terms of rising costs of
living for households in Europe many due
to spiraling energy and food prices
the consequences of the current crisis
have an impact on Supply chains
commodity and energy prices in the EU
affecting many sectors of our economy
and especially as a means and so
affecting the overall economic activity
as well as the revenues and purchasing
power of households
the European Parliament and its recent
resolution of May 19. on the social and
economic consequences for the EU of the
Russian war in Ukraine called for Action
to address the economic and social
crisis in a coordinated manner
mitigating the impact of energy prices
on vulnerable households and supporting
them to ensure a fair green transition
with a view to containing poverty while
the EU freeze itself of dependence on
Russian energy Imports and on fossil
fuels
Parliament also stressed the importance
of preserving social resilience against
the background of a possible
deterioration of the economic and social
situation engendered by a protracted war
in Ukraine spiraling prices and high
inflation we fully share your concern
and we carefully listen to your calls
which are in line also with the social
pillar and its action plan
in times of Crisis we must increase our
efforts towards the implementation of
the pillar on key issues such as the
fight against poverty and inequalities
decent living and working conditions
labor market integration of vulnerable
groups investment in skills and
effective social protection what is at
stake now is the social creation which
obviously has a wide political dimension
we already experiencing a significant
rise in inflation in the EU above eight
percent in June 22 up from around two
last year this is holding back to
Recovery in the latest EU economic
forecast EU GDP growth for 22 has been
revised downward from four percent to
2.7
the combination of fire inflation and
mute muted wage growth is significantly
eroding the purchasing power of
households and increasing the real cost
of living in particular for low-income
households households it is utmost
importance to respect now social
Partners autonomy and I want also to
underline the importance of social
dialogue at all levels to cope with this
important economic and social challenges
vulnerable groups of citizens and
workers have been particularly hit by
the covet crisis as well as the previous
financial crisis the most vulnerable in
our society bear the brunt of the
consequences of the current geopolitical
crisis and the war in Ukraine it is up
to us as policy makers to act and be the
Europe that protects
assessing the distribution of impact of
inflation and Rising living costs and
mitigating the adverse effects of these
developments on the social situation is
of the utmost importance for the
Commission in this regard I am confident
that different initiatives that we have
been working on will be key in in the
coming months and years let me mention a
few examples the directive on adequate
minimum wages is expected to create a
positive momentum for measures enhancing
their adequacy the European child
guarantee will support children in Need
by breaking the intergenerational cycle
of poverty and inequality and we just
heard that the Czech presidency invests
a lot in developing this and
strengthening the implementation of this
child guarantee the forthcoming
recommendation on adequate minimum
income will support those who find
themselves without any means to find
their way back to society and special
labor market
the communication of October 21 on
tackling Rising Energy prices provides
policy guidance to member states on how
to support households between October 21
and mid-February 22 alone member states
adopted measures in line with the
toolbox which eased energy bills for
around 71 million households customers
and micro small and medium-sized
Enterprises we recently established the
energy poverty and vulnerable consumers
coordination group with member states
they will discuss the implementation of
emergency measures and examine their
evolution
in his communication of March 8 22
repower EU joined the European action
for more affordable secure and
sustainable energy
the commission provided guidance on the
application of fiscal measures on
windfall profits with a view to
redistributing revenues to final
consumers these measures can play a key
role in mitigating the social and
economic impact of high energy prices on
vulnerable households as well as on
companies especially smes tomorrow's
plenary debate on taxing windfall
profits of energy companies will provide
an important contribution in this
context on the uh May 18 in response to
the consequences of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the commission put forward the
repower EU plan the plan aims to achieve
Energy savings diversify and secure
energy Supply and accelerate the green
transition by the rollout of Renewables
while stressing that our joint action to
accelerate the clean energy transition
reinforces the need for Effective
employment skills and social policies in
line with the European pillar of social
rights we call oncologists to adopt it
swiftly member states can rely on
financial support at the EU level and
the European Parliament also rightly
called for the continuation of financing
support for as long as needed in
particular the European social fund plus
provides funding for supporting children
and young people and promoting social
inclusion and tackling material
deprivation the funds under the recovery
and resilience facility are being used
by member states to enhance social
resilience and social cohesion which
accounts for around one-third of
national plans as well as to address the
structural courses of energy poverty
support repower EU
225 billion euro is already available in
loans under the irf now it is up to
member states to update their recovery
and resilience plans as highlighted by
president vondolai
this transition will either be working
for all
and be just or it will not work at all
and the newly proposed social climate
funds
aim to address the regional and social
impact of the green transition including
energy in line with the fair transition
principles of the fit 455 package in
this regard proposed limitations by
college status on fairness focused
Investments should not lead to
insufficient capacity to address
negative distributional impacts
during the pandemic we successfully
mitigated the risks unemployment thanks
to the sure instrument
clearly it is an EU success story in
2020 that supported approximately 31
million people almost one third of total
employment in 19 beneficiary States
in the new future
we have to collectively reflect on new
Innovative instruments to modeled on
previous instruments to protect the
citizens especially the most vulnerable
and to tackle challenges related to the
reduction of purchasing power and Rising
Energy prices
the current social and economic Outlook
requires further coordinated efforts
between the EU member states and social
Partners to tackle the emerging
challenges related to the reduction of
purchasing power to respond to the
evolving crisis and the deteriorating
situation our economic and social
governance mechanisms under the European
semester are an invaluable asset namely
and the revised social School Board
which monitors member states progress
towards battle skills and social
fairness we will follow up on the debate
on the review of the EU economic
governance framework as well as on the
reform of the EU owned resources
including the introduction of new own
resources we need to build on the
experience of the past two years where
we have collectively been able to put
the European pillar of social rights at
the heart of the eu's recovery one that
this attainable inclusive and fair the
challenge now is to keep the recovery on
track to address the rising cost of
living in the current crisis that is
also the message and spirit of Porto the
pillar it's action plan and the three
ambitious social headline targets for
2030 must drive our joint efforts for
fair green and digital transition
since the porter social Summit the EU
has continued working towards more
social and economic fairness and
resilience and we are ready to pursue
actively these key objectives we heard
parliament's call to organize a
follow-up to the port of social Summit
to discuss the challenges of the
extraordinary situation we are facing
with increasing inflation and its social
consequences I share the view that we
have to address these pressing issue of
rising cost of living in the EU in a
coordinated Manner and at the highest
level the commission will obviously play
fully its role thank you
thank you very much commissioner for
your very important and comprehensive
intervention in our debate
now we will continue
um
move on to political group spokesman
and the first one is on behalf of the
European people's party and it's from
Isabel benhumir one and a half minutes
please
thank you we see growing inflation
it's rocketing in Europe
this is mostly punishing families
independent workers smes it hurts anyone
who's involved in economic activity but
anyone who's trying to make ends meet
and
things have got more expensive so Europe
has put forward a stimulus pan due to
covid this will inject European funds
unprecedented funds we're talking about
the next gen funds as we've just heard
from the commissioner we also on the
table have we also now have the repower
EU plan on the table Europe has shown
solidarity now we have to make the most
of these funds so that they actually
help to address this challenge we need
to reduce inflation and we need this
money to reach companies and smes and
families so they can move forward
when the member states change their
National plans
they must include lower taxes tax cuts
which will cushion the blow of price
Rises and of inflation
reducing
taxes so that energy and electricity
costs are lower they also need to be tax
breaks
which will
Foster innovation
and growth the commission should
encourage the member states to make the
most of what already exists the next gen
funds and the member states should be
encouraged to take the necessary reforms
and adequate Investments so that we can
deal with the problem of inflation today
thanks very much our next speaker is
from the snd group
two minutes please
[Music]
war in the Ukraine Energy prices and
food prices are going through the roof
and people struggle to make and smeat
while putting is cutting off plus glass
supply to entire countries
capitalists make profits by speculating
on markets and thereby hurting millions
of households and like I said people
making ends meets are in trouble to make
ends meets while companies benefits with
huge profits so we need to have a profit
windfall tax and use the profits from
this text to mitigate social
consequences of rising Energy prices and
inflation
we need to coordinate European action
now to avoid a crisis in this winter and
I think we cannot wait until the social
climate fund is in full action
we need to action now we have a European
solution in the sure instruments and we
need to extend this program to help
households and companies to survive the
winter I'm urging the commission Council
to gather with social Partners to take
the leads
please present a minimum income schemes
directive as soon as possible and
explore the possibilities of energy
price gaps for basic consumptions for
households so no one is Left Behind
we need to be bold and we need to tackle
the crisis now heads on thank you
thank you very much next speakers in the
renew group Luis Gary Kano one minute
please
step history teaches us that when
inflation reaches these high levels it
takes discipline and patience to bring
it under control but the ECB is entering
this battle against inflation with one
Thai hand tied behind his back
a decade after Euro crisis our economic
and monetary Union is still deeply
incomplete first we have not created a
safe asset for the Europe area and as a
result money flees to safety from the
south to the north placing highly debted
State under more stress second we still
don't have a single Deposit Insurance
the ministers a couple of weeks ago
abandoned the road map to build one
third we still don't have an instrument
for common borrowing
um this is this place the ACB in the
situation of having to support highly
indebted member states which is not his
job fourth we lack an enforceable set of
fiscal rules now the ACB announces an
anti-fragmentation tool in order to be
able to raise rates and well they have
to know they shouldn't be naive they
will be tested and the truth of the
matter is that
they do not have any long-term solution
this is a non-strategy of temporary
fixes which is going to run out of Road
very soon out of control inflation is
always a very hard problem to solve by
continuing to neglect these structural
problems there is a risk that European
leaders make these crises fatal for the
Europe thank you
thank you
next speaker on behalf of the green
group is Ernest one and a half minutes
please
thank you very much
inflation is really hurting families at
the moment Staples have gone up energy
food all of that affects the lowest
income families
and the European Central Bank is trying
to deal with inflation
with an inadequate tool a blunt tool of
raising interest rates it may worsen
things but not everyone is dealing with
the Fallout in the same way
we need to look at inflation and how
it's distributed because some companies
are making huge profits they're making
big business out of this we've heard
that electric companies electricity
companies made more than 200 billion
euros
same with the food companies the Agri
industry has passed down costs directly
to Consumers we therefore need to act
and we need to work swiftly in various
areas the European Council must tax
windfall profits then there needs to be
a true energy transition that means
changing the electricity market so that
we can better include Renewables then we
need to help lowest income households
and boost social protection that means
including help to the most vulnerable
families as was done in Spain by the
government we also need to have a basic
minimum income in uh
we basically need a
new tax
and we need to look at bifid because we
can't agree on bifid in this plenary
these are some of the measures that we
need to help the most vulnerable against
the impact the dramatic impact of this
crisis but let's not forget that there
are actors on this Market who are making
huge profits due to this inflation
thank you
our next speaker of the ID group is yak
medicine one and a half minutes please
so much Mr chairman thank you for Mr
from the council commissioner as you
said very very right way that is a very
important topic I think it's the most
important topic before the winter and
it's so important that we have in
disciplinary we have almost 20 MEPS
listening to this debate I think we have
10 times more people there on the
balcony our visitors anyway just about
inflation about economical problems I
would like to just mention two things uh
first of all we asked last year from the
ECB from the Central Bank of Europe
how will affect their very tough green
policy green deal to the European
economy and to say it very clearly yes
it will affect
it will increase inflation didn't say
how much but they said yes it will
affect and the same thing is mentioned
several times in the speeches and in the
public opinions by Mrs Isabel Schnell
Isabel Schnabel who's a German Economist
member of executive member of the board
of the ECB as you say same things if we
are crushing
discreet till forward it will affect our
economy that's a pure fact
and if you're looking now on the energy
sector
and if we imagine what will happen in
few years
if we are of course hating so much all
the nuclear power and fossil fuels and
we're just hoping for the wind and sun
and I love also sun and wind it's
amazing things but unfortunately it's
not enough it's not enough of our energy
sector it means the price will go even
more up it will much more higher and
that's just economical fact so that's
why I would like to just hear your
opinion in today when we have war in
Ukraine we have this kind of problems in
energy sector and we see the result of
the green deal in those first year here
actually what is your opinion what is
the position of the commission are we
still going forward with in my opinion
crazy idea absolutely crazy idea uh or
are there any plans that we actually
will react to the problems what we have
already today so that's just my only
small question and if you can answer I
would very grateful thanks so much
thanks very much
next speaker is from the ECR group and
it's Johann Von Overfelt one and a half
minutes please
foreign
commissioner colleagues thank you very
much we need to implement policy which
will address the problems of energy
the climate and purchasing power because
all of these policy areas are
interlinked and we've got to realize
that the measures that we take to tackle
climate change have an impact on energy
supplies and in turn a major impact on
purchasing power
we have got to make sure that we protect
our energy storage and we can of course
have recourse to gas and to call but
that will have an impact on the climate
the purchasing part debate of course
ties in very closely with the whole
issue of taxonomy colleagues
my party colleagues are very much in
favor of a sustainable energy transition
but we also feel that competitiveness
and prosperity for the citizens is
essential we've got to be well aware of
the very difficult political situation
which we operate but the Fallout for
individuals is great the impact on the
purses of wallets of the citizens is
huge and if in the long term we want to
get control of electricity places and we
want to have stable
Supply policy in energy and we want to
do something about the climate problem
we are really going to have to have
recourse to nuclear energy we're going
to be talking about taxonomy the
parliament is about to recognize that it
should be deemed to be a green
transition fuel I think we've got to
recognize the consumer purchasing power
mustn't be any further undermined
industry needs competitiveness and we
need to have the appropriate fiscal
instruments to deliver on this thank you
thank you
my next speaker is
Lam let me know from the left one minute
please
thank you when I was a young student a
professor said to me
capitalism is the end of History
we see that the time of Crisis and Wars
is over but since then there have been
countless Wars and crises
and what I know is that after every
crisis the gulf between the rich and the
poor grows wider Euro crisis Corona
crisis the attack on Ukraine
and the geopolitical sanctions imposed
by the EU
all of these are borne by the People by
the workers
bread fruit and vegetables electricity
energy everything is
going up we safe companies
but
workers are supposed to forgo any wage
increases and at the same time we are
paying for Armament the Richer become
richer the poorer become poorer
how
we don't need people to forego wage
increases instead we need a price break
on crude oil we need to prevent perverse
wealth
and I think that we're going to have a
hot Autumn of social protests and people
will be saying we're not going to pay
for your crisis or for your Wars anymore
thank you
thank you
next speaker is one of the non-attouch
members Laura Ferrara who has one minute
thank you Mr President the increasing
the cost of living is having an impact
which needs to be urgently addressed by
European governments not just in Italy
but domestic expenditure and rents fuel
Water Energy prices and raw materials
this is always of course feeding into
inflation as well the ongoing War gives
rise to various questions on our energy
dependence and speculations in the
market
and one solution would be ceilings for
gas and petrol prices
it's also important that we use European
funds correctly here including Next
Generation EU and the ESF plus support
for the recovery and helping smes
economic and territorial cohesions need
to be accompanied with particular
attention to those most vulnerable parts
of our society let's have minimum wages
to allow workers and their families to
live decently thank you very much
thank you says the president now we move
on
to backbend speakers and the first one
is Dennis Radko as one minute president
thank you Minister commissioner
colleagues the current crisis has got to
be tackled
with new ideas rather than the ecb's
chart
untested arguments we've really got to
focus on the essentials under what we
can do in pragmatic terms
the climate social fund which we have
been discussing and indeed adopted
recently shows precisely why
we need to take prompt action the German
Chancellor is reluctant to do precisely
this and the package that he's put
together really does very little to help
pensioners or students and this
Chancellor is in fact
simply dithering about the social fund
the climate social fund and doing his
best to make sure that there's at least
possible money in it
but we have got to try to make sure that
the states have their money
from this budget so that we can tackle
the escalating food prices for example
so that we can guarantee jobs and so
that we can ensure that industry is
shielded from the impact of all the
price costs escalation but also for
example the chemicals and legislation
and we've got to get together with the
social partners and ensure that we can
come up with
effective policy thank you
thanks very much next speaker is Ms
Bischoff two minutes please
thank you president
Minister commissioner
we have the European pillar of social
rights
and we came up with that in the
aftermath of the financial crisis and
the social crisis in many member states
we didn't know that shortly afterwards
we would be wrestling with even bigger
crises affecting everyone we saw the
pandemic but we as the EU managed to
come up with good instruments
but I'm worried I fear that this autumn
and winter will be a real test of our
solidarity in Europe
there's this question are we just going
to come up with nice speeches or I'll
are we going to do what Mr Radka said
push this all to the National level or
are we going to come up with European
plans and strategies it's not just about
dealing with energy poverty and security
it's about people who are afraid people
who are afraid they can't pay for
heating people who are afraid that the
money in their pockets will be worth
less and less due to rampant inflation
I therefore think it's a good thing that
the commission is going to do everything
in its power for a social Summit I turn
to the comet I want to turn to the
Council of you for me
um do you understand if we don't get a
hold on this if we don't get a grip on
this
then Europe and the world will change
we therefore really need measures
it's already been said we should cap
Energy prices
we should tax win for profits those with
low and medium incomes should
uh have their burden uh
removed from their shoulders but we have
a real uh different set of situations
one from one member states the next some
capping some not but when I look at this
room I get the impression that we
haven't yet got our head round the
severity of this situation so what is
the answer from the commission what is
the answer from both Council and
commission that's different from
business as usual
thanks very much our next speaker one
minute please very much chair I will
talk in Romanian
their colleagues
we've been talking of later about the
lockdown generation now we should admit
that the pandemic and the Russian
aggression in Ukraine have brought to
the surface
socioeconomic vulnerabilities the member
states are more and more inducted
deficits are growing and income of the
citizens are wasting and melting away
from a man to another it is no solution
to throw money at them from helicopter
improving the daily life comes from
reform Investments and building strong
social resilience also with the support
of National Recovery and resilience plan
improving the daily life will come from
the strength we give to the young people
now and not later on we should invest in
the younger Generations now and not
later we should invest in their
education now and not later we should
create opportunities for entrepreneurial
Spirit the young people should believe
that they can renew your we are in
charge to open their door to Europe we
need the brave measures first
unprecedented measures to avoid
generation that would go back to a
living standard much worse than their
parents or their grandparents that is
why the social pillar of Rights in
Europe can lead us to a better life for
all citizens thank you
foreign
thanks very much our next speaker
is Ms laganzeepen one minute please
thank you social justice
is the glue which binds our society
together and when we no longer have this
in the European Union we have a
democratic deficit a serious problem
with democracy social justice is a
weighty term
the minister has referred to this
and indeed has said that it is an
important concept and it means that
we've got to prevent people falling into
poverty but the reality is that for all
the action program for social pillar and
all the policy proposes that there have
been over the years too many people are
suffering from social exclusion and
poverty 15 million people
more in recent years so the member
states have got to
have a reality check here because it's
all very well to talk about objectives
and talk about the social climate fund
and even the minimum wage and attempt to
coordinate social security systems which
has never yet seen the light of day it's
already it's already well to argue
endlessly Ad nauseam about how you're
going to achieve social Europe but
you've got to do something because the
Citizens need security they have no
security we've got to have more than
simply a minimum income on which people
can't even live for the future of our
children and our grandchildren for our
future and for the future of democracy
we are better Europe thank you
thank you
next week
one minute please
thank you Mr President
exploding prices bills rocketing up EX
salaries and purchasing power
drastically reduced these are the
situations our Citizens need to address
every day and we have to sort out as
rapidly as possible we want to stop
millions of families in in Italy and
Europe buffeted by energy social crisis
which is unprecedented we need rapid
genuine Solutions before this
degenerates into explosive social
conflict but in this tragic context what
we're seeing is the wedi proposals of
the Italian left in Italy during this
devastating crisis the left's priority
on his political agenda is to liberalize
cannabis and give citizenship to
immigrants that's enough of this
nonsense it's enough talk
what we need to do is stop following the
lift which is living on a different
planet and look at reality in straight
in the face we need to sort out these
real problems and we need to start
sorting them out now before it's too
late
thank you very much our next speaker is
mikhil jorgevane for one minute please
don't confronto foreign
thank you for people at home life is
simply unaffordable inflation is through
the roof the electricity bills fuel for
cars gas bills food in the supermarket
everything is going through the roof day
by day the causes of these are a lack of
energy policy and the fact that we are
still holding fast to ridiculous climate
ideas and ridiculous sanctions on energy
the sinking problem is that we don't
have a proper Finance policy being
implemented by the central banks by
buying up debt and by crazy funding
policies such as Next Generation EU we
are simply accelerating and exacerbating
all the problems which inflation brings
in its wake so what can we do for the
people back home we could be saving the
billions on these crazy climate policy
initiatives we could make energy
affordable and accessible with all that
money we need to see that it's time for
us to implement the reforms that the
unity the European Union has been crying
out for for years this is what the
people want the people want us to change
the EU so that it actually serves their
interests and protects them thank you
thank you very much
I now give the floor to Mr Eunice omargi
for one minute
president
president commissioner
as we speak
a minority of speculators continue
to make profit from this crisis and this
war at the same time European people are
suffering they are suffering from the
spike in prices across the board across
all sectors particularly foodstuffs and
energy
and we have to admit it after the years
of the covid crisis the European people
are exhausted
exhausted because their living standards
continue to worsen
despite having made so much effort
what they expect from us today are
immediate decisions
and
a capacity in these exceptional times to
take exceptional measures to tax
those who are involved in the crisis
so that multinationals don't continue to
make
these huge profits we should control
Energy prices and we should reduce VAT
on Staples we should index salaries to
inflation and we should increase the
European fund for the most vulnerable so
that everybody is able to eat a decent
meal three times per day president these
are immediate decisions
that would actually have an impact
these decisions would help millions of
European people to actually survive to
actually live and not just survive to
thrive but not just survive
d
thank you very much
the next speaker is Mr York Martin for
one minute president colleagues
we're talking here about initiatives
that might deal with inflation
now we should all be well aware of the
fact that the consequences of our
failure were entirely predictable the
central bank's policies have failed they
have failed there are zero rate
policy and they're huge Bond buying
program have simply conjured up this
inflation inspector predictably out of
what seemed like nowhere we have seen
what the inflation rate is in
Switzerland at some three percent
whereas here it's already over eight
percent and that's on an average so the
ECB president Lagarde and her governing
Council are guilty they get they are the
guilty parties because of failing to
comply with their Mandate of price
stability the impact on this is born
first and foremost by the most
vulnerable the least well-off there are
no proper social policy initiatives to
mitigate the impact on the poorest it's
all just a bit of tinkering with the
symptoms in the belief that this is some
kind of Panacea but it's not the
restrictive monetary policy has simply
delivered very bitter
medicine already but we've got to
realize that more of this is necessary
and with the middle of God we're not
going to see what we really need to see
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Miss Eva medal for one minute
thank you Mr President
in the Eurozone and the European Union
we have record inflation households have
to choose what they can buy and what
they can't because they will have almost
10 percent less the European Union
started as a peace project and
prosperity it has given us is very much
what keeps us together today people like
Europe because it gives them a good and
secure life
do you see my spot
unfortunately okay
can I ask you to uh to restart your
intervention please
I'll ask
the inflation in the Eurozone and the
European Union has reached record levels
households have to choose what to buy
and what not to buy because they will
have 10 percent less
we must not forget forget that the EU
started as a peace project but economic
Prosperity it has given us is very much
what keeps it together people like
Europe because here they have a peaceful
and secure life
today we are taking a very firm and
clear position against Russia's
aggression we have voted on sanctions
and an embargo and these were the right
steps but in order for them not to be
too heavy for Citizens we need to take
specific actions and specific measures
that are practical and well targeted we
need to support vulnerable households
but also business in its um
growth because only strong economic
growth can compensate for record
inflation thank you
thank you very much
and I'll give the flow to Mr Pedro March
for two minutes
thank you president
good afternoon Council
commission I'll speak Portuguese because
I want the People Back Home to hear me
we're faced with an enormous social
crisis in Europe
yeah
European companies are and households
are going to require Investments so that
they can meet their fuel bills it's time
to do something we're hoping for
proposals from commission over the
summer so that we can prepare for the
winter in the European Union
look at Bulgaria three person family so
it's about a 25 percent of their income
on energy
and
there's supposed to be a 30 increase in
Energy prices for the forthcoming winter
things like rent fuel transport energy
all of these prices are going up and
there's also of course the question of
gas supplies
so we need a coordinated response from
the European institutions
that's why we want a social Summit to be
held
in the next few months we need to do
something about energy prices
because the prices don't reflect normal
market conditions and are hurting our
economy and our citizens we need to
help those families at risk of poverty
because of high energy prices we need to
help the millions of Ukraine Ukrainian
refugees who are in Europe who are
fleeing a war we need to make sure that
the sure mechanism dealing with
temporary or employment is maintained
and kept going and also to finance all
of this and work at European level we
need a tax on these ludicrous profits
being made by energy companies during
this process that could pay for all of
these European initiatives
we can't put this off any longer we need
to start making these responses
immediately the crisis is already here
and our citizens want our support before
the Winter thank you president
thank you very much
the next speak is
for one minute
dear colleagues everywhere in Europe are
the cost of living is rising in an
unprecedented manner in this situation
it is legitimate for a government to
introduce price capping on fuels in
Hungary it happened during the election
campaign but the elections are now over
and the government
would now like to get rid of the capped
official prices but it doesn't dare to
do so because it's afraid the hungarians
would be angry with the government what
does a populist a smart populist do in a
situation like that well they will ban
discounted fuel for any foreigners so
only Hungarian citizens will be allowed
to buy a price capped fuel of course
this is against your European rules but
that's the point the government would
like the European commission to launch a
procedure against the government so that
it can then uh blame the European
commission for the price hike so I'd
like to ask the European commission not
to believe in what the Hungarian
government is saying and not believe in
this setup or trap
together
thank you very much
the next speaker is munir Satori for one
minute president
commissioner Europe is the second
biggest
Powerhouse in the world
despite that millions of people face
poverty and social exclusion 22 of
people
can't make ends meet they don't have a
decent life
and we look to Autumn but things are
currently acceptable we need to do away
with mere National measures people don't
want charity they want dignity and their
rights to be upheld the European project
must be our social Shield we need to
have a minimum income in all member
states that needs to come to light so
that everybody can live in a decent way
and they must be above the poverty
threshold we must continue with the
environmental transition make it uh just
and ensure that it creates decent jobs
but we also need to have
and energy policy which will reduce
energy costs for households we need to
have a minimum wage and we need to focus
on health and housing and food stuffs
thank you
thank you very much
the next speaker is Christian Terrace
for one minute
Mr commissioner their colleagues
the definition of insanity is to do the
same thing over and over again and
expect different results
we talk now about the increase of cost
of living in the European Union which is
just a result of the insane and unsung
policies promoted by the European Union
since Ursula on the line took office
Ursula's plan to forcibly change the
behavior of Europeans through higher
prices and higher taxes as she said
calls and unseen inflation in the EU and
more poverty than ever seen before
the solution to make the cost of living
in the EU more affordable is to reduce
taxes so businesses will have more money
to invest and create jobs as well as
people who have more money to spend
must understand that she cannot text
people out of poverty as she cannot in a
market where demand for energy is
increasing get cheaper energy by closing
down sources of energy nevertheless the
European Parliament must stop the insane
and support
the creation of energy from nuclear and
gas that along with the with the
renewable energy can provide sustainable
and cheaper energy which will make the
cost of living affordable for all
Europeans thank you
let me cover together
thank you very much
the next speaker is aniko Guri for one
minute
dear colleagues the inflation that has
been caused by the war can only be
stopped by Peace So the most important
thing is to aim for peace on the
continent we have just recovered from
the crisis caused by the covet pandemic
we have to gain strength
by reducing taxes reducing burdens for
Citizens and Enterprises Putin's
aggression has
speeded up the green transition but we
cannot make people pay for this
otherwise the EU will get into poverty
as a whole
it is important to fix the prices of
basic foodstuffs as Hungary has done
the commission should recognize that in
extraordinary times it is Extraordinary
Measures Brussels should help member
states to protect families
they should
stop
stop
hindering member states from helping
their own citizens otherwise the
European Union is going to become some
kind of Museum where the Chinese
tourists visiting Europe can see how we
used to live
thank you very much the next speaker was
supposed to be Mr Schwab who is not here
so I give the floor to Mr edogle for one
minute
president
minister
commissioner Schmidt
we're talking today about inflation
throughout the European Union the
currency Union and of course this is in
part related to and a consequence of the
terrible attack perpetrated by Putin on
Ukraine but we need to look reality in
the face and we need to face the truth
and that is that the ECB has also failed
if inflation's gone from four to eight
percent because of the war it was still
at four percent before the war and would
have been without the war and that still
double inflation
double the figure which the ecb's
Mandate dictates and therefore that is a
clear definition of failure we need to
have a system which does not create
inflationary Spirals and therefore we
need reform in the European Union of
course that means we need to discuss
many other things like how to manage the
crisis and what our role in shaping
policy response should be but we can't
just go from more debt to more tax
greater tax burdens and spend 200
million a year coming to Strasbourg
without drawing the consequences we're
throwing money out of the window and
taking on unnecessary debt and not even
thinking about all the CO2 emissions
which we're generating by coming to
Strasbourg in the first place therefore
we need to think about reform right
across the board and in context not just
uh Somewhere In The Ether thank you
thank you so much the next speaker is
vice president Mikhail simechka for one
minute
thank you Mr vice president Mr
commissioner dear colleagues the cost of
living crisis is indeed affecting
everyone and especially low income
households but I would like to focus on
one group in particular and that is
young people because for too many young
people in too many member states even
obtaining their own uh their own housing
has now become an almost impossible
problem an impossible challenge in 2020
the share of young people living with
their parents was over 67 percent in the
EU and that was before the war that was
before the pandemic and before this
crisis as rents and property and
property prices grow housing as such
basically becomes inaccessible to
millions of young Europeans regardless
of their social status
and now of course we must think about
how to tackle inflation and energy
prices but I would really like us to see
and I would really like to see a
long-term solution for affordable
housing to ensure that nobody is Left
Behind and that young people have the
opportunity that all the generations
including my generation have taken for
granted thank you very much
thank you so much now we move to the
catch TI procedure we have five requests
and if you stick to the time we can give
the four to all five beginning with
Miriam laxman
thank you very much the conference on
the future of Europe ended two months
ago and while in Brussels or Strasbourg
resolutions are being adopted on
starting the convention on the revision
of the basic treaties of the EU the
citizens are concerned by different
things especially the consequences of
the pandemic as well as the war
increasing prices of energy and food
foodstuffs and we need to bring a quick
Speedy resolutions
that's why I stress that the opinions on
the future of the EU from the 21 member
states were not reflected in the
conclusions due to the chaotic
organizational issues up until now we
have not received official translations
into all EU languages including Slovak
what is the signal we are sending to the
citizens in this way recently
I had a survey commissioned in Slovakia
which clearly says that the citizens
want from us uh reactions to the uh
increasing prices and to lower wages
because uh three-fourths of the
interviewers said that they are not
going to be able to cope with the
increasing prices EU unfortunately often
acts in the areas where it doesn't have
the competence and often we can bring
Solutions it doesn't act thank you
thank you very much the next speaker
for one minute
thank you president the vast majority of
the population in Portugal and Europe
has had to face enormous price increases
cost of living is increasing wages and
pensions can't keep pace
production costs are going up for
industry as well
and we have speculation and Despicable
profiteering from this situation
we're talking about providing more money
for militarization and War but
governments are refusing to invest in
public services or help the most
vulnerable people in their countries we
need measures which go beyond being
palliative we need to address the
question of the cost of living increases
and wages and obviously a national
minimum wage
we need to do something about precarious
jobs we need to increase national
production substituting Imports and
guaranteeing fair prices in particularly
in the ugly food sector thank you
president
thank you very much
the next speaker is left
for one minute
prices like energy fuel on food are
constantly increasing this is a
consequence of the green taxis and the
green switchover
we're gonna have a difficult summer
and winter as well and people are
suffering from inflation as well as all
the other problems I've already
mentioned we see the huge profits being
made by the energy companies and we need
to do something to protect them from
this worsening crisis what we need to do
is deal with the
end the imperialist war in the Ukraine
do something about energy and fuel
prices and make certain that
all of the domestic
forms of energy including lignite are
actually used and taken advantage of
thank you very much
thank you very much the next speaker is
for one minute
foreign
[Music]
let's see if it can be solved
now it's possible or not yet
please I'm waiting for information on
that or I can speak in English
[Music]
um
so
can I have information from
the
interpreters
okay so yes fine so let's try let's try
again
um from the beginning please thank you I
will I will repeat very briefly
commissioner
let me thank you
for the approach you're pursuing I want
to thank the vice
prime minister of the Czech Republic who
is heading up the council presidency
this is going to be a tricky period
the impact
being felt on social policy
will be dealt with by the member states
but there will also need to be
assistance provided by the European
commission you've spoken about important
programs that the member states can use
these have been around for quite some
time such as the European youth
guarantee by what the member states
should do is use
their recovery plans and renovation
plans member states should do everything
in their power to help families and smes
I think we need very targeted support
and I would also support what was said
by Ms lexman
we need to not Overlook subsidiarity
because member states can provide
solutions to this situation and then at
EU level we need
to
deal with what is within the competence
within the remit of the EU let me wish
all the best for the vice prime minister
as he tries to deal with the social
Fallout that we're currently facing
thank you
thank you very much
we end that series of speakers but first
of all we hear from Mick Wallace
president
the Russian Ruble is at a seven year
high
inflation reached a record high in the
Eurozone in June the people of Europe
are struggling to survive due to the
crushing cost of living compounded by
sanctions on Russia that are not of any
use to the people of Europe
we are letting the war mongers ensure
the destruction of Ukraine and the
collapse of living standards across
Europe and driving Millions into poverty
in the global South
we're spending billions of Euros making
sure the war in Ukraine continues we're
spending billions of Euros on the
militarization of the EU since the
invasion NATO countries have committed
billions to military equipment in
Ukraine war is a profitable business the
shares of BAE Systems the largest
weapons manufacturer in Europe has risen
by 32 percent since the start of the war
the best way to deal with the cost of
living crisis is to stop prolonging the
war the people of Europe favor peace
even well above punishing Russia
we can
do something positive about bringing an
end to the war today is the EU has made
no serious effort for dialogue and
diplomacy we have prioritized the
military Dimension from the start
foreign
thank you very much
now
to close this debate
we hear from the commission and the
council
first of all the commissioner Nicholas
Schmidt
Mr President
I first Want to Thank The Honorable
members for this
enriching debates
I think we all
sharing
the fact that
especially households but also companies
as a means are suffering from this price
increases
and we all convinced that we have to act
boldly to
mitigate this situation
when we are talking about the courses
I'm a bit surprised
because first
it seems that we have forgotten that
before the war there was a pandemic
and this pandemic has already pushed
prices High
because a lot of value chains have been
interrupted
when you talk to uh
some Industries they cannot get
the material they need
so there is a bright side which is due
to the pandemic
the second one is that we are moving
into something which is quite close to
war economy
and we should call it like that
that the situation is not a normal
situation which can be easily resolved
and we know where the responsibility
lies
the responsibility first lies
there where the war has started but the
decision to regret an independent
country has started and was taken
and I'm I think that we just cannot give
in to such an aggression which would
then be an invitation to pursue on this
kind of aggressions
now we all know that
in a exceptional periods
in an exceptional period
markets do not normally function
and we are driven in many areas not by
normally functioning markets but by
incredible speculative
movements which has pushed
food and energy up
and when you look at the
inflation it's mainly pushed by
the price Heights of energy and food
beside the courses I've mentioned on the
on the value chains
and those who now say that it's because
of the green deal that we have inflation
they just do not tell the truth
because we have not yet seen finally
some real impact of the green deer so
how we we see now that even coal uh coal
um factories are we launched so we have
not yet seen any uh real impact on on
this by the green deal but what we know
by the way is that due to the war
climate change is continuing climate
change does not wait
it's just there and we have seen it now
recently again in Italy with this
catastrophe
so I think that we have to be now
serious on really trying to mitigate the
impact of inflation and therefore social
is so important because social means
that
we have to work on the cohesion of our
societies because there is also
speculation
speculation on dividing our societies
even more
on on
creating new kinds of of Divisions
inside our societies but also among
European countries
and therefore I think the best way now
to deal with this
is not each member State individually
certainly a lot of measures have to be
taken individually by member states but
what is needed now is a good
european-wide coordination
in order to make sure that we are not at
the end
dividing Europe in those who are able to
help and those who have more
difficulties to help and this is a poor
issue this is the unity of the Union is
needed more than ever now and therefore
unity means
working on social Europe working on the
principles of the pillar but adapting
also our policies to the exceptional
situation of something which is close to
a war economy we are going through and
we have to give convey to our citizens
the real messages that we are ready to
help we are ready to support
their purchasing power the way how they
have to try to make ends meet as it has
been said by colleagues but also to have
companies who will be affected by the
fact that they have energy problems the
prices but also perhaps the supply of
fundamental energy will be blocked by uh
especially by the by the Russians and so
it's not the sanctions who have created
inflation it's the war mainly it's the
fact that markets are overshooting due
to speculation and when the OCD
agent International Energy agency
considers that about 200 billion special
windfall profits have been produced by
the fact that markets are not rationally
behaving anymore and some certainly take
their advantage out of this then I think
we have to draw the right consequences
from that and not put into question now
the green deal which is an issue which
we cannot escape from thank you
thank you
thank you again commissioner for your
very important intervention in our
debate and now wishing all the best for
the Czech presidency I give the forward
to the minister uh Nicolas Beck Eve
California
Mr President honorable members
thank you for this vigorous debate on an
urgent topic
uh we learned many lessons with the last
crisis but perhaps the strongest one is
that we have to show our unity and our
determination
I remain confident that the targeted
measures at National level and the
instruments adopted and coordinated at
the EU level will prove to be effective
in protecting the most vulnerable groups
and the people at the risk of poverty
I very much agree with what was said
that we need a European coordinated
effort and that member states need to be
encouraged on how to best use and
Implement instruments and policies that
are already in place
and yes as Mr rutka said this crisis
will be tackled with new innovative
ideas not with business as usual here I
agree with Mrs Bischoff
let's have in mind that this price
increase crisis has some of its roots in
the energy sector
Energy's prices hikes are partially
linked to the overall uncertainty on the
market which is constantly nurtured by
the Russian war of aggression
our common goal should be to bring
predictability and certainty to our
energy providers back that is why our
regulatory framework is developing so
fast and you all mentioned them repower
you plan fit 455 package and also
taxonomy climate delegated act which
this house is going to vote about
tomorrow a few of the many examples
Mr President on all the members we will
continue this discussion also in the
context of the debate on taxing of
windfall profits of energy companies
which I look forward to
but already now I would like to reassure
you that the council will do its utmost
in the line with its competencies to
tackle this unprecedented challenge
the debate along with action will
continue at the European level
we will have a social Summit ahead of
the October's European Council which
will for sure deal with this issue I
would like to close my brief remarks
with thanking you for giving me the
opportunity to participate in this
fruitful discussion thank you very much
foreign thank you very much
with that final comment this brings us
to the end of this debate
we can then immediately Press On
and move to the next item on our agenda
that is the report by Mr kenyas
EU action plan for the social economy
may I remind you of the rules for this
debate they are identical to the rules
for previous debates
and I'll start by giving the floor to
the wrap towards her
Mr Canyons you have the floor
thank you president
I'd like to start
my